We can take these two images together,
these motion energy images and
this motion history image, and
together we refer to them as what
we call the temporal template.
It was just the model
of how stuff moved.
All right?
And then we tried it on
a dataset that we created.
We had this person who was
way more fit than we were
do a whole bunch of different aerobics,
different moves.
And we just said, okay,
can we now recognize if somebody
is actually doing a new routine,
which aerobics move she's doing.
All right?
And one of the interesting
things that you can see here,
what I'm showing you here are the MEIs,
all right.
I'm just showing you the binary version.
And you might say, that this shape,
looks an awful lot like that shape.
But if I show you the motion history
image of the one on the top,
you see that, and you can see,
that it's dark down here,
and light up there, so that's an example
that the arms are moving upward.
When you take a look at this one,
you can see that it's high up here,
but high down there, so
it's actually going like this.
So the motion energy
image would be ambiguous.
It shows you where the stuff is.
But the motion history image
resolves that ambiguity.
The motion energy image
captures the whole image
motioned area and captures it nicely.
So that's why it's not in some sense
redundant with the motion history image,
which gives a lot more weight to
the more recently moving pixels.